good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-1269 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures site 1265 which contains SCP
1265 is to be publicly maintained as a
wildlife preserve by the safe and clean
planet initiative a foundation front
company scientific discoveries made by
the foundation regarding wildlife within
scp-1269 corresponding evidence being
found in the fossil record civilians
wishing to travel through scp-1263-a
class-d and terra grade and selectively
amnestics in order to be unable to
remember instances of scp-1269 come into
contact with all untreated civilians
found to have come into contact with a
CP 1265 eight instances are to be
treated with class a retrograde or
general amnestics implanted with false
memories and released every six months
eggs laid by instances of scp-1269 cube
ation and study before being released
into the wild and maturity full
procedures for care of young specimens
of scp-1269 printing procedures c
document 1265 one description scp-1263-a
land measuring 50 kilometers within the
congo basin africa scp-1263-a
Cryptococcus 15 kilometers is contained
within the neighboring Republic of the
Congo the majority of scp-1263-a entails
flora typical of the congo basin
SCP 1265 is inhabited by several species
known to be extinct mostly from the clad
Dinosauria these animals collectively
designated as scp-1269 taneous li in
groups of five approximately once every
30 days and are not necessarily found on
the fossil record within Africa instead
they appear to be selected based on the
climate they lived in during the
Mesozoic era instances of scp-1269
Cassie P 1265 as they D materialized
upon crossing the border of scp-1269
and reappear in an area three kilometres
of the border sedated SCP 1265 a are
also not chosen based on one particular
period of the Mesozoic but the
Cretaceous and Jurassic are the most
well read with sparse population of
Triassic period dinosaurs in addition
several non dinosaur reptilians such as
pterosaurs are known to exist within
scp-1269 Lee scene SCP 1265 a instances
even carnivores show no aggression or
fear towards humans unless provoked
to date the three foundation personnel
killed n scp-1269 loking a 1265 a
instance as opposed to being actively
hunted by a carnivorous species of a CP
1265 a notably there are a few large
carnivorous or herbivorous dinosaurs
present as scp-1269 stencil and a lack
of dinosaur species whose fossils have
been found in North America for example
species such as Tyrannosaurus Rex and
Brachiosaurus have never been cited in
SCP 1265 but species such as Spinosaurus
and Kentrosaurus are relatively common
proportionally speaking there is a five
to one ratio of non American dinosaurs
to American species
finally there are several instances of
scp-1269 been discovered in the fossil
record collectively known as scp-1263-a
instances are known for being unusually
aggressive and will often charge ad or
attempted to attack researchers and
other animals within a CP 1265
indiscriminately as of yet foundation
researchers have been unable to
determine the origin of most instances
of scp-1269 found on the fossil record
and as such have been reclassified as
incidences of scp-1269
scp-1269 Stinson reclassified as a CP
1265 a usually lose all aggressive
tendencies as CP 1265 is believed to
have existed for at least 200 years
according to historical records several
instances of scp-1263-a of several
tribes in the area near SCP 1265 for
further details see interview 1265 one
interview 1265 one an interview
conducted by dr. wells in am boshi
village 5.5 kilometers away from the
perimeter of scp-1263-a our dang a CP
1265 a sightings all dialogue has been
translated by acid from the Lingala
language playing log they do not eat
people though not most of them except
for that woman baby boomer own ad is
like a big snake with legs walks on all
fours like a dog has a big Ridge on his
back I will eat you if it touches you
tell me that McKellen McKellen Bambi is
the largest of them all it is big enough
to block rivers and makes the lakes rise
it can be under water but it is not a
fish
and the arts shakes with it works there
is also a beetle in balloon build the
beast with planks in its bug these
mccallion the middle yes and now these
do not have feathers everything else is
right what if Dino has feathers so does
McElveen they are almost like bars in
that way but they do not fly the ones
that will fly have no feathers what else
can you tell me about the area it is
hexed the michaelis andean beetles and
others cannot believe it without
vanishing nor can they eggs or me years
ago hunters tried to bring back the
carcass of a Micheli it took the whole
village and when they reached the edge
of the area
it simply vanished how many people are
coming to the area over the past seven
years many they are hunters but they do
not want to kill they wanted to find
more telling and nothing else
they never succeed for whatever reason
it is because they do not look in that
one area for gaming we tell them it is
dangerous and it is all people know that
that area is dangerous and not to go
near it
now thank you for your cooperation no
administration of amnestics was deemed
unnecessary due to the familiarity the
majority of the village had with
scp-1269 collected notes regarding a CP
1265 a notes taken during a monthly
expedition through scp-1269 eel I still
find it fascinating that almost all
instances of scp-1269 asuras at least
our feathered
not scale all I have to say is this gen
eat your heart out this blow Gian out of
the water
Hwang's came across a few carcasses and
he's joked a few times about wanting to
see what they taste like
I don't trust dinosaur meat especially
given what was found at that farm in
China there are some trilobite s-- in
the water however and the natives
sometimes come here to fish for them
they taste like prawns as noted in the
main description the majority of them
are from the clad dinosaur II and are
all suited to fit the climate of the
congo several of them are quasi
amphibious such as the Kentrosaurus
which prefers to spend time in water
observation has shown that it can hold
its breath for up to an hour at a time
as such
Kentrosaurus native to this area have
large amounts of algae growing on their
plates and spikes occasionally giving
the illusion that they are a living Bush
of some sort Kentrosaurus are also quite
docile but we've seen that there thank
an take down small trees
despite the theory created by mister
Russell in the 1980s there is absolutely
no evidence that Troodon would have ever
evolved into the so-called dinosauroid
but are rather intelligent they have
been seen using rudimentary tools in a
manner similar to chimpanzees in order
to pick fruit from trees and throw rocks
at prey in order to injure it
we found a family of Baryonyx today as
it turns out there semi-aquatic and used
their tails to shoot through the water
after fish and chop them up like a
crocodile or girls they appear to be
associating with a clan of Spinosaurus
dr. Moore was very disappointed about
seeing a live Spinosaurus and I honestly
can't blame him they're mostly
quadrupedal and have feather covering
more like ducks than anything else their
skeletal structure is completely
unsuited for walking upright and the
less said about the so called spine the
better scientifically fascinating but as
a lifelong dinosaur enthusiast I must
grieve for such a Titan we've made an
incredible discovery a four winged
flying dinosaur with wings on both its
arms and legs Wang speculates that it's
a completely new species of Microraptor
native to Asia it's colored like a raven
its plumage is an iridescent black since
it's not been found in the red cord it's
an alpha instance and those things are
tetchy when nearly got his finger bitten
off sedating it if it's ever found in
the fossil record will name it properly
but for now it's just Microraptor
foundation I we finally found something
that isn't feathered it's the species of
crocodile posto saccas Late Triassic it
was drinking at the edge of a lake when
suddenly a pack of Coelophysis jumped
out and attacked it several of them went
for its throat cutting the jugular
as soon as if bled out they began
stripping the corpse to the bone it was
astounding almost like a piranha tearing
apart a cow in the Amazon we managed to
collect the skeleton and when noticed
that the thing had three shattered
ankles as if they'd fallen or landed on
their feet probably why the Coelophysis
were able to take it down so easily
we saw a magnificent fight between Sarah
Xena Soros and a carnotaurs the
therizinosaurus practically decapitated
the poor carnivore which was about the
same size
the therizinosaurus corpse and dipped
its claws in the blood before scouring
the trees are rounded with dinosaur
blood I believe that this was done for
the purpose of marking territory it's
actually rather fascinating if somewhat
gruesome if there is in a store then ate
a bit of flesh from the carnotaur and
left the area dr. Moore had apparently
never seen it done lava Soros outside of
a certain movie he was absolutely
shocked when he saw one and it wasn't a
2 meter long creature that acted like a
dog but rather a 6 meter long creature
that looked like he could bite off his
head it ran away but we managed to get
some good pictures also found some
footprints from an unknown sauropod I
honestly have no idea what on earth we
saw today we found a new instance of
scp-1263-a Sarah Thompson with a single
horn and four short stumpy legs but it
had a long tail dragging along the
ground uncharacteristic of Sarah
Thompson and it didn't have a frill of
any sort instead it almost seemed to
have floppy ears near the top of its
head it was also quite aggressive and
was engaged in combat with a [ __ ]
rhinosaurus for unknown reasons and
ended up going the poor thing we decided
to head back to the site after that
I like dinosaurs just as much as the
next guy but go into the Congo yeah
I'll stick to Steven Spielberg Thanks
anyway I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to albino Neku GM's Sabah Andre de shirt
Jax Marek
Pablo ice 917 Burlington the cat all the
time gaming Justin day researcher bull
veer Pierce M Hamlin Curie kuma white
crew Nicholas James vu Jack Bryce and
Billy my archive curator Nick cootie
tench the Android slump god quartz 5 6 3
i'm tree hero thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the Volgin thank you
[Music]
you